bon anniversaire à astérix qui souffle
ses 35 bougies au prix de 23 francs le
journal exceptionnel d'astérix se rend
hommage au petit gaulois roublard créé
par le duo uderzo et goscinny
les bénéfices des ventes iront à
l'association les petits princes qui
s'occupe d'enfants atteints du sida
josé dans la pierre photo de famille
pour les 35 ans d'astérix
ils sont tous là les râleurs les
teigneux les bagarreurs bref le
tempérament gaulois selon uderzo records
de vente de la bande dessinée dans le
monde entier
261 millions d'exemplaires
les très célèbres aussi chez nous encore
et nous avons aussi beaucoup de t-shirts
avec astérix
j'ai passé l'âge
quand on a lu à la plupart des albums on
a fait le tour quand même c'est pas
c'est pas parce qu'à l'acte est riche et
à 35 ans astérix ne veut pas vieillir
seule solution suivre la mode
aujourd'hui la bd c'est plutôt pour les
collectionneurs à leur place au dessin
animé bientôt sur notre écran en fait il
n'a pas dû la prendre cinq ans de vie
pour nous mais bon c'est pas personnes
âgées qu'il n'y aura pas ça c'est sûr le
bonheur que peuvent avoir les héros de
bande dessinée ou de quoi que ce soit ou
d'un moment ils n'ont pas d'âge et
toutes façons ils ont toujours le même
âge quant au papa il avait lui 35 ans
quand astérix n'en avait que trois mais
pour l'inventeur du village qui résiste
à césar pas question de penser à la
retraite
30e aventure je veux les premiers
électeurs pour l'année prochaine l'ours
l angoisse parce que j'ai absolument
aucune idée je ne sais pas du tout ce
que je vais faire mais bon à chaque fois
c'était l'angoissé puis quand même d'un
seul lot le secret de sa réussite
uderzo ne se l'expliquent pas mais
quelque chose nous dit que c'est
peut-être la fidélité à ses personnages
on pourrait faire